an injury yesterday for the kansas city
chiefs to discuss clyde edwards hillaire
great rookie running back came out of
the gates strong diminished a little bit
after that le'veon bell has been getting
more and more play there as he's gotten
comfortable in the chief's offense
edward zelaire is expected to miss the
remainder of the regular season high
ankle sprain x-rays negative may be able
to return for the playoffs
i think it's important for him to be
back but if you start listing skill
position players
on the chiefs that they don't critically
need
i
i i think
one of or both running that that's where
you start because you go you find
another running back because running
back is not a critical piece of the
puzzle we know damian williams had a big
contribution last year in the postseason
specifically in the super bowl but there
are running backs out there the guys you
need are the receivers the tight end the
quarterback if you're going to start
losing skill position players running
back will do the least damage to the
interest of the chiefs
and we saw that yesterday mike le'veon
bell came in and had his best game he
had 12 carries for 62 yards and a
touchdown that nice 12-yard touchdown
run and i think they can put their faith
in le'veon bell he's played a lot of
postseason games he has that experience
that frankly cloud edward teller doesn't
have considering that he's a rookie so
they're fine with le'veon bell they're
fine if if he were to get hurt in the
next two games i think as you said they
would be fine as much as they throw the
ball as good as they are at the other
skill position
and with the tight end that they have
they are good with whoever they have at
running back we've seen that we saw it
last year when they won the super bowl
there was no superstar running back and
we all felt like they got better
drafting clyde edwards hilaire in the
first round uh this year but they are
fine without him too mike
he's got 808 rushing yards on the seas
and he had 138 week one against the
texans which was a long time ago but
feels like not that long ago one other
100 yard game 26 carries for 161 in the
win over buffalo other than that it's
all over the place it's as low as 14 32
37 you mentioned that bell had 62
yesterday edward zelaire had 79 so it's
not a critical blow to the kansas city
offense and he hasn't been
as he was the name he was the hot name
for rookie of the year remember that
going into the seas and everyone's like
oh clyde edward's a lair and he you know
everybody wanted to draft him on the
fantasy team he hasn't delivered and i
feel bad for him coming into the nfl
with that weight of expectations he
didn't deliver the way that that we had
expected
and now uh his regular season ends with
808 rushing yards and we'll see if he's
back for the postseason the chiefs
though shireen to amplify a point that
we've made on pft live i posted the poll
yesterday we've had well over 25 000
votes and the majority of the people
responding
when the choice is chiefs
versus the field to win the super bowl
the majority is saying chiefs and look
the playoffs are exciting and you see
who gets a seat at the table and
anything can happen in theory but
i feel like
if i had to pick one if i was gonna
wager any amount of money or anything of
value or anything i cared about i would
say the chiefs over the field i'd take
that bet
oh i would too mike it's an easy bet
right now they look like the best team
but i would say this i mean going into
last season last postseason i think we
thought the ravens looked like the best
team too right they had the mvp they
were 14-2 they were rolling at that
point you felt like they were going to
get to the super bowl and maybe win it
but of course they had the chiefs
standing in their way and and didn't get
there and and so you never know what can
happen but there is no reason to think
that the chiefs won't do what they did
last year i do think they're gonna play
some tough playoff games we saw it last
year and you've talked about this
repeatedly about how many times they had
to come back every single game they had
to come back come back come back and i
think we're going to see some games like
that but i'm not betting against patrick
mahomes and the chiefs with the way
they're playing right now unless
something happens in the last two games
i'm with you if i was going to bet
anything i would bet it all on the
chiefs right now
more than twenty four thousand six
hundred votes fifty five point seven
percent say chiefs forty four point
three percent say the field and the
first comment i'm looking at from
top hutch 76 the field too many
variables and now i'm starting to doubt
my conviction in the chiefs but you're
right
t.a hutch too many things can go wrong
all it takes and i don't want to say it
i don't want to say it for fear of being
accused of applying the jinx
but all it takes is one specific thing
that happened during the 2019 regular
season that can derail the team's hopes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports